since my last conference i'm going to
take a moment just one more moment of
your time to get up on my soapbox about
today you will see in our exhibitor
tables there is a group emotion matters
which are right outside the group the
door out here and they have ipads they
are have a campaign of advocacy for BPD
and their particular movement right now
is about this petition it is a petition
to increase funding for borderline
personality disorder research at NIH
this is a very important cause and I
will explain why in a moment because
it's not always clear to people why this
is vital if you want research if you
want treatment for BPD to be developed
if you want to understand the mechanisms
underlying this disorder this is how we
do it this is how we fund it and if they
aren't funding it then it's not going to
happen it also will lead to a decrease
of trainees involved in the disorder I
will show you how to sign the petition
but also why it's important this is the
change.org website for it you can see it
is a letter to Bruce Cuthbert NEA has
been very supportive of this as well and
they have contacted Bruce Cuthbert and
he actually very quickly responded and
set up an appointment they are meeting
with him a week from today is that right
yes a week from today we have one week
to add more supporters to this petition
so when they arrive in Bruce Cathcart's
office they can show him how many of us
out there are really behind this idea so
that's why I'm going to ask you today to
take a moment to take your cell phones
to go to the table out there where we
have iPads and please please sign the
petition please tweet it please share it
on Facebook on other social media and
please let people know why this is so
important let me show you why this is
funding from ni-mh for different
disorders we have over here depression
schizophrenia this is the number of
dollars in millions that ni-mh is giving
to these disorders this is BPD this is
from 2009 to 2013 if we look at 2016
physical year 2016 this is absent zero
I know colleagues of mine I am one of
these people applying for these and they
tell us not to bother don't bother this
is why your signature on this petition
is so important when people think about
BPD research they think of us here at
Yale that that maybe the university is
sponsoring the research the University
graciously provides us with the
resources the infrastructure to do the
research but us paying for those
expensive imaging protocols for that
time slot for that nurse for that
clinician to do that work we have to
have external grant funding to do that
and ni-mh is the biggest provider of
that grant funding if they aren't
funding it it's really not happening
there's very little research for this
otherwise and this is really important
because this also is the funnel for the
next line of researchers in BPD Seth
Axelrod and I both completed
postdoctoral training fellowships on the
same ni-mh grant here at Yale and you
see what that did we stayed here we kept
pursuing and focusing in our research on
that disorder that is how we get the
best and brightest of the next
generation to focus on this disorder is
through that having these grants and
then having trainees come and work on
those grants it is vital to it and
without this funding we will lose a
generation of researchers focused on BPD
so I'm going to ask you to please go to
this website or more easily I did this
myself google search BPD and change org
and it will pop up as the first link and
you can select it and go to it easily
rather than typing and everything and
then once you sign it I'm going to ask
you to retweet to post it elsewhere and
please let other people know how
important this is because this is really
vital the research you will see
presented here today it's going to be
it's funded by NIH that's that's how it
happens and if we don't have that
funding if we don't have the ground
swell of support for this then we won't
have more funding so that is my soapbox
and that's what I'm asking for everyone
if I get you guys to sign up for this
petition today then all the work I've
done on this conference is well worth it